well wouldn't it be nice not to be glued  to your phone for an entire day when is  the last time we've done that  that's the idea behind national  unplugging day the pandemic has forced  all of us to be on screens more than  ever before  so tomorrow is dedicated to taking a  break  i think the thing is to realize is that  what i want to do with my time  when i'm not working or i'm not in  school  so the campaign suggests activities like  getting outside or joining other  joining their scavenger hunts rather i  don't know what scavenger hunts those  are but apparently that's part of the  campaign  they also recommend locking up your  phone if you have to  to avoid the temptation yeah sherry even  if we wanted to get a break a lot of us  can't do that no but i tell you what  with the warmer temps that are coming  even into tomorrow  unplugging would be a great idea